in 1961 the SCP Foundation discovered a
town that was completely devoid of all
life not long before their arrival
Darrington North Carolina had been a
community with high aspirations a deeply
religious Township of devout Christians
many of whom were seeking greater
Prosperity from their lives but now
their home was a ghost town with no sign
of any prior Darrington resident to be
found where in the hell had they all
gone it oddly seemed like the population
of an entire town would all
simultaneously decide to up sticks and
leave two pastors new but then again
maybe the citizens of Darrington hadn't
left at all perhaps they weren't even
really still human and had taken up
residence somewhere much darker like
underground this is the story of one of
the earliest known instances of a
phenomenon now known under the
designation of
scp-3089 or to use its alternative name
that old time religion when the SCP
Foundation arrived in a desolate
Darrington to find the townsfolk had all
vanished they immediately began an
investigation into the exact house and
whys the answers to what exactly had
happened here after all while not a huge
Place Darrington was home to nearly a
thousand residents and that many people
don't just disappear if they even had
disappeared and weren't just dormant but
what the foundation uncovered was a
gruesome discovery that led them to not
only demolishing the entire North
Carolinian town but purchasing all the
land around it to keep the area under
permanent observation prior to the
demolition however the ministry of
Sevenfold blessing had been one of the
oldest buildings in Darrington much like
most Town churches and it was while
searching the offices of this church
that the foundation cleanup Crews
discovered their first piece of evidence
the initial clue about what had happened
to this deserted town they recovered a
series of cassette tapes each with a
recording of sermons that have been
given within the ministry of Sevenfold
blessing these were all delivered by One
Pastor Bartholomew Jenner the first
having been recorded on August 17th of
1959 two years earlier my friends I want
to talk to you about what the Bible
offers tonight Pastor Jenner began in
the first of these recordings I want to
talk to you about what you are owed I
want to talk to you about I want to talk
to those of you who are struggling right
now to those of you who have hardship
and pain maybe you've heard that the
Bible only nourishes the spirit that God
only provides for our Immortal Souls
well my friends I'm here to tell you
that this is simply not true Pastor
Bartholomew Jenner seemed to be focused
on the discussion of very real relatable
problems after all what person hasn't
felt unsatisfied with their life at one
point or another and this was apparently
no different for the people of
Darrington many of you can think of
places in your lives where you have not
yet risen where you are not yet
Victorious marriage finances hell but do
not fret my friends God wants you to
rise he is cleared a path it is one
littered with his Earthly Treasures to
claim them you only need to shed your
old selves and be reborn the pastor was
merely using the shared faith of the
township to help reaffirm that their
struggles were not the be-all and all of
their lives or at least that's how it
first appeared but the religious
practices taking place in this first
recording would soon take a bizarre turn
making it clear there was something far
more Sinister even cult Mike going on in
the ministry of Sevenfold blessing now
if you would some of the ladies from the
mayor's office were kind enough to
collect these cicada shells pass along
each of you take one yes the children
too be careful very careful they are
fragile each of you take one and hold it
in your left hand yes the last left hand
not the right your left the shells of
dead cicadas hardly seem like common
fare for a sermon like this although as
the recording continued it was easy to
understand that Pastor Jenner intended
these discarded insect carapaces to be
something of a metaphor even if they
were pretty gross especially to some of
the younger members of his congregation
he explained to the Darrington residents
that these cicada shells Were Meant To
Be symbolic of whatever hardship the
citizens were currently struggling with
in their lives whether it was work a
marriage or an ill family member then
came the next part of this unorthodox
practice the pastor instructed everyone
in the congregation to picture
themselves holding their biggest problem
in their left hand now I want you to
squeeze your left hand squeeze it into a
fist feel that problem cracking like old
dried out paper Philip crumbled to dust
Jenner told them the residents of
Darrington did so crushing the cicada
shells until there was nothing left
everyone open your eyes don't you feel
better strong this is what is offered
our hardships are like the shell we
shall cast them aside even as they
crumble God has cleared a path needless
to say the foundation agents that
recovered the tapes of Pastor Jenner's
odd sermons weren't exactly sure what to
make of them and as unusual as they were
the recordings did little to indicate
where the townspeople of Darrington
North Carolina had disappeared to but as
they listen further what they found was
even more unsettling than an entire
Congregation of people crushing cicada
shells in the second recording dated
December 19th of 1959 Pastor Jenner was
once again presiding over his
congregation he had just finished
quoting a passage from Matthew chapter
25 verse 30 which related to a Biblical
tale known as the parable of the talents
in this story a master puts his servants
in charge of a differently sized portion
of his wealth while he is away then
judges them based on whether or not his
servants make a profit using his money
the third servant who had received the
least talents meaning an amount of money
was punished for burying his share in
the ground cast out into the outer
Darkness to face weeping and gnashing of
teeth it was after making mention of
this unprofitable servant that Pastor
Jenner went on to address even more of
the bizarre almost ritualistic practices
he had been introducing to his sermons
now some of you have expressed concerns
over the new sacraments of you have even
called them sacrilege and yet have we
not prospered have these same naysayers
these same doubting Thomases not
profited from all good works the pastor
declared I have shown you how to heal
the sick with the Lord's Prayer and the
blood of an unbaptized child I've shown
you how to see your future in the
stemming entrails of equivalent grow
I've shown you the path to Glory but I
cannot make you follow this path I can
only show it to you it is you and you
alone who must follow it who must rise
and share your old self shed your old
self the words immediately call to mind
the image of the cicadas insects that
discard their outer carapaces and emerge
Anew bugs that also burrow into the
ground and wait lying dormant under the
Earth for years at a time all before
they emerge rising up again so they can
spread it was becoming clear that Pastor
Jenner was certainly deviating further
and further from the the church's normal
religious practices his bold and blatant
descriptions of what sounded like
ritualistic sacrifices were shocking
enough to hear speaking of using blood
and entrails to bring the town the
prosperity it sought but if that wasn't
bad enough the worse was still yet to
come contained within the third and
final recording unlike the previous
cassettes most of the sermon from June 7
1960 was almost completely
unintelligible and without any Visual
Evidence to go along with it it was hard
for the foundation to make out exactly
what was going on it began with another
quote from Matthew This Time chapter 28
verse 6 which made mention of the
resurrection of Jesus that he had risen
and that people should come and see
where the Lord lay not a metaphor my
friends Pastor Jenner explained before
urging his congregation to join in some
kind of formation stat followed mothers
behind their daughters fathers behind
their sons turn to face the uh the
recording became unintelligible again
after the point with only a few more
words being audible the pastors seem to
have gathered the townsfolk of
Darrington presumably for some new form
of ritual he encouraged the town's
children to close their eyes and pray
before reminding the congregation that
God sacrificed the life of his only son
Jesus frighteningly it appeared that
Pastor Jenner was implying the adults of
Darrington should do the same one of the
next fragments of his sermon that could
be deciphered declared lamb is
slaughtered to feed the lion the sun is
slaughtered to fade between more and
more noise interfering with the
recording Pastor Jenner could be heard
saying The Pact is complete this WOW
shall be our Paradise before he
encouraged his congregation or those who
were left to dig deep and wait then came
perhaps the most horrifying part to the
tape the remainder of the recording
lasted 30 minutes comprised of pure
static or the foundation agents
listening to it assumed at first that it
was just interference but further audio
seem to suggest that the long continuous
mass of hissing wasn't static at all it
was The chittering Sound of Insects like
the noise made by cicadas for a Time the
incident at Darrington left the
foundation baffled there seemed to be no
clear answer as to what had happened not
one of the town's residents were
anywhere to be found and on top of that
there were no bodies no remains of any
kind to speak of if they were dead there
would at least be some kind of trace and
then there were all the questions raised
by Pastor Bartholomew Jenner's strange
sermons why do they seem so focused on
enacting rituals did any of his methods
really benefit the town and why did he
place so much emphasis on cicadas of all
things answers were few and far between
although almost six decades after the
foundation discovered the desolate town
of Darrington a new development would
come to light to be more accurate it was
56 years later on the 11th of January
a foundation agent named Daniel Mitchell
was patrolling the area that had
formerly been Darrington North Carolina
before the foundation had demolished all
traces of the Town by this point the SCP
Foundation had long thought that they
had figured out exactly what scp-3089
was they had even encountered it
emerging in a number of different forms
in both 2007 and 2015. however it was
what Daniel Mitchell happened across
during the routine monthly Patrol that
revealed the horrifying Truth at the
outskirts of the area where the town had
once been a series of sinkholes had
opened up at some point between the
previous monthly check and this one in
early 2017 and if you think that these
sinkholes caused a disturbance in the
earth and uncovered all the bodies of
the former residents of Darrington you'd
be wrong it was Far Far stranger the
foundation conducted a full-scale
examination of the sinkholes around the
demolished North Carolinian town and
these weren't just a few patches of
loose ground that had sunk through
through the Geological Survey the
foundation carried out quickly revealed
that these sinkholes led to an extensive
network of tunnels underground they
extended several hundred kilometers
outwards practically covering the entire
underside of where Darrington had been
the tunnels seemed far too big than any
other created by any natural means but
the entire network also appeared too
rudimentary too imperfect to have been
carved using any modern excavation
technology like a large drill plus if
any equipment like that had been on site
the foundation would have noticed as
they kept the area monitored it was
almost like something had been burrowing
through the ground only to eventually
crawl back up to the surface resulting
in the sinkholes what's more of the
foundation's geological tests suggested
that the network of tunnels was almost
four decades old that would have placed
the date of their creation about 10
years after The Disappearance of
everyone in Darrington naturally the
foundation immediately launched a
mission to explore more of the
before even completing a full sweep of
the underground space in its entirety
they had made another Discovery
contained within the tunnels was over a
whole ton of organic material that had
been mostly preserved without
decomposing too much the SCP Foundation
began Gathering samples for testing
fighting most of this material to be
severely desiccated dermis tissue that
is the dense layer of skin beneath the
epidermis and it had all been entirely
dried out but that wasn't all the
testing uncovered according to genetic
analysis the tissue had two distinct
types of DNA present the first being
easily identified as human genetic
material which made sense despite the
material lacking in moisture the dermis
tissue didn't match the skin of any
other mammal but then there was the
other DNA present combined with the
expected human DNA was the presence of
something else that the foundation
researchers had quite some difficulty
finding a match for eventually they
determined that this genetic material
entangled with the human DNA belong to
the sycadata Montana better known as The
New Forest cicada cicadas again cicada
DNA mixed with human DNA discovered in a
large network of underground tunnels all
beneath the same town where a pastor had
his congregation crushed cicada shells
in their left hands during one of his
sermons ten years before the sinkhole
incident the foundation was alerted to a
particular YouTube channel by the name
of Kai Sanchez positively rich on the
surface Kai was one of the many online
grifters preaching about how easy it was
to quickly achieve an obscene amount of
wealth by simply believing in yourself
usually if not always these types of
people were trying to scan Their
audience of loyal subscribers into
investing in some kind of illicit
money-making scheme or any number of
other cons promising their followers
easy money that never came bakai
Sanchez's channel was slightly different
so much so that the founder station had
to contain his entire audience deeming
them to have been affected by
scp-3089 the video that caught the
foundation's attention was an hour-long
upload from Kai entitled seven secrets
to ascend the ladder of prosperity there
was that word again Prosperity the same
thing Pastor Jenner had promised his
entire congregation in Darrington and
the similarities didn't end there in his
video much like the pastor during his
sermons Kai Sanchez encouraged his
audience to visualize their success in
order to achieve it he implied that the
human consciousness could impact reality
for example if his viewers just imagined
themselves having a bigger bank account
or looking more attractive then these
things would manifest themselves into
the real world one of Kai's secrets to
ascend the ladder of prosperity was as
follows the visualize your ascendance
reimagine yourself as someone who can
reach the top of that ladder shed your
old identity tear it off throw it aside
like dead skin you won't need it not
where you're going the resemblance to
Pastor Jenner's sermons was uncanny
Kai's video even encouraged that his
audience leaves scraps out to lure
strike cats into their homes and then
once they had one to take a knife and
well you remember what happened in
Darrington but Kai Sanchez made sure to
specify remember to hold the knife with
your left hand another online community
was tagged by the foundation for similar
teachings this group of insular men were
trying to apply the same methodology
primarily to attract women however they
also reasoned it could be used to
improve their own financial status and
physical stature all done through
visualizing and believing that doing so
would make these things improve that
having faith would grant them Prosperity
this Disturbed Community even tried to
use bug Rattlers to emit frequencies to
Aid and try attracting women contained
within these Rattlers were the preserved
remains of cicadas male cicadas have Tim
balls structures on their outer shell
that emit a loud hissing chittering
noise that they often use to find a mate
after spending so much time dormant
underground before burrowing up to the
surface and if you've been paying
attention you might be able to guess
exactly where this is going
scp-3089 is a phenomenon that occurs
within communities of people who are
seeking some form of prosperity whether
that community be a town a group of
like-minded people online or any other
group of collected individuals the
particular type of prosperity these
people are all seeking can be anything
from spiritual enlightenment to
financial success the SCP Foundation
does not yet quite understand exactly
how scp-3089 starts only that the
community is affected by it will attempt
to achieve their chosen material Success
Through the application of rituals like
visualizing what they hope to overcome
and Achieve and practicing sacrifices in
short these people have to believe these
acts will grant them what they want they
need to be willing to go far enough to
do unspeakable things they need to have
faith although what they don't realize
is some things can feed on that Faith
they can Harvest it before these
communities realize the terrible things
that they have done or who exactly has
tricked them into performing these
rituals they'll begin to undergo a
horrific transformation process known as
scp-3089-b it begins in the Chrysalis
Stage members of a community that have
been affected by scp-3089 Will
experienced a decline state of
metabolism now classified as an instance
of
scp-3089-a their brain activity heart
rate and body temperature will all begin
to lower over a period of between three
and six hours these people will then
suffer a change to their epidermis the
outer layer of skin it starts to harden
until it does form a dense brittle
substance like a shell next comes the
second stage of
scp-3089-b metamorphosis internally
scp-3089-a individuals will develop a
number of tetramas a type of germ cell
tumor that can contain several different
types of tissue such as hair muscle and
bone during the next two or three weeks
these tumors will expand and dissolve
the person's soft tissue then there's
the final stage emergence an instance of
scp-3089-a will exit its dormant state
that began in the initial stage once
they have awoken then something exits
the outer epidermal shell it will not
communicate some will retain remnants of
internal organs such as eyes or lungs
however these are vestigial no longer
serving any purpose the brain functions
deviate from any normal human patterns
having completed the process the this
thing will attempt to burrow down into
the soil via any means at its disposal
an outer shell digging into the soil the
tunnels underneath Darrington the
genetic material uncovered below dermis
tissue with two types of DNA a mix of
human and cicada there is something out
there it is preying on people's Faith
their longing for Prosperity than when
these communities are presented with
someone who can take advantage of that
Faith Like Pastor Jenner or Kai Sanchez
they find themselves encouraged to push
their faith to its furthest limit and
then they are rewarded by becoming
something else something nightmarish the
question is when they wake up and crawl
back out from their tunnels leaving a
sinkhole in their wake where do these
cicada creatures go want to own an SCP
of your own go to scpswag.com for
premium anomalous merchandise now go and
check check out scp-3004 insect God
Imago and scp-2852 sadistic madman Party
Crasher cousin Johnny to uncover more
information about a pair of anomalies
with a surprising connection to that
old-time religion